nerf john wick is basically a long
intense gunfight
[Music]
the intensity we were able to achieve
partially comes from the sound design
and that's what i want to talk about
i want to show you how i created the
sounds for these nerf blasters in this
video
i need to make them as intense as real
gunshots so i'm going to have to follow
one of the key rules of sound design
it all comes down to the layers and
mixing of multiple sounds to create the
illusion of a single intense sound now
hopefully after this video you too will
be convinced that you don't need the
most realistic weapons to make an
awesome fight scene for your next
project
all the gear and software that i use to
record and mix nerf john wick are in the
description below a disclaimer i do not
have a degree in sound design this is
not a sponsored video in any way i
learned how to do this by doing it
let's go
and that's the video thanks for watching
just kidding okay let's look deeper into
that scene
first i'm going to mute some sounds so
that way you know exactly the sounds
that are being used
basically that's a recording of me
firing a nerf gun and repeating that
sound effect every time nico fires the
gun for the darts hitting everybody i've
recorded me flicking a nerf dart with my
finger
i added some plastic foley sounds from a
nerf gun i recorded right before the
shots start firing
let's mix that all together quick and
see what we have so far
this sounds great but it just sounds
like a normal nerf blaster there's no
strength no velocity no true impact so
now i'm going to add some design
elements to really amp it up
first i'm going to add some punch sounds
can't forget to add a solid slap to
really hit a comedic punch line and a
much more unique dart sound that has a
tail on it to really hit that punch
[Music]
now that we've given some strength to
the darts we need to make them more
dense so what i'm going to do is make
sure that we have some solid falling
sounds when the goons hit the ground
next we're going to add speed i have two
types of sounds i'm specifically going
to add for this
first whooshes some solid pvc bushes
that i got from the film riot sound pack
i love these things
then i'll mix in a pre-designed bullet
sound that implies the idea of a
dangerous gunshot
now let's listen to all of them mixed
together and balanced
as you can hear reality isn't enough
it's important to experiment with
layering different sounds which can
create more depth and complexity
sometimes sound design is not about
perfectly recreating a sound but instead
communicating an idea
experiment is key there is no one way to
make a sound
[Music]